all right ladies Tim Burton what do we
got well I can do something in his new
film miss Peregrine's Tom what's that
stubborn oh man I'm going to work out
how Bert Ernie that's not a word movie
is watch right
okay next idea anything you see if it's
in Burnet movie kind of scheme love
interest guys
the poem is going crazy that idea is too
obvious do we have something a little
less obvious we could do something on
Tim burns canceled movie projects in the
immortal words of dr. Frasier Crane I'm
listening
I think perfect oh my god there is no
way we are not featuring that tomorrow
thoughts me in the bernama are in
alright it's settled
six canceled Tim Burton movies that
would have been cool as
to Jurassic Park
all right quick history lesson it's the
early nineties and Batman is a
monumental success with a box office
gross of around half a billion making a
young timber and the hottest property in
Hollywood but just how hot Ruby rhod so
much so that Warner Brothers wanted him
to direct a movie adaptation of Michael
Crichton's Jurassic Park
yes the Jurassic Park however after a
fierce bidding war Universal Studios
secured the rights and hit up et
director Steven Spielberg who reportedly
been interested in the project before
the book even had been published hipster
the rest obviously is history and we can
only wonder what timber in Jurassic Park
would have looked like for starters the
dinosaurs would likely all look stringy
and sad and everyone's favorite
paleontologist and paleobotanist couple
Sam Neill and Laura Dern will be out on
Burton it couple Johnny Depp and Winona
Ryder will likely be in maybe it was for
the best actually
why Burton's fifl ed Catwoman never hit
our screens is your classic sad tale of
studio meddling while Batman Returns was
a great success it didn't quite light up
the box office like Batman did and so
Warner Brothers opted for a lighter tone
for its follow-up Batman Forever as
evidenced by this highly accurate
reconstruction but how do we lighten the
tone of Batman greatest comedy actor of
our time in put nipples on the Batsuit
all right let's put nipples on the
Batsuit Batman Returns screenwriter
Daniel waters even pinned a script for
Catwoman which involved Selina Kyle
getting amnesia and going to relax in
the Vegas esque oasis burg Oh which just
happens to be run by secretly evil
superheroes sounds weird but honestly
eight out of ten would watch sadly
though Batman Forever made more money at
the box office than returns did and so
while that movie was and let's be real
here absolute trash Warner Brothers
decided to keep milking that amusing
cash cows bat nipples dry which is why
we ended up with the dumpster fire that
was Batman and Robin and this is why we
can't have nice things
yeah Ronis with you it's difficult to
believe that Tim Byrne hasn't had an in
history of the Adams family except for
stealing the whole aesthetic in 2010 it
was announced at illumination
entertainment and Universal had acquired
the rights to everyone's favorite creepy
coupe key mysterious spooky ookey family
they planned on making a kid-friendly
stop-motion animation so who's better to
bring on board than everyone's favourite
creepy kooky mysterious spooky ookey
director at this stage Burton had
already made the corpse bride produced
The Nightmare Before Christmas and was
deep in production on Frankenweenie so
it wouldn't be a far cry to imagine his
stop-motion take on The Addams Family
boom was attached to co-write and
co-produced the stop-motion animation
feature until it got coke and Angie in
it got completely kin
Timber and Superman lives is the mother
of all canceled films
it would have been unlike any Superman
story ever done in comics movies or TV
before it would have taken everything we
know about the character and turned it
upside down why are you bringing up such
painful memories I've just last year
finally recovered shaking loosely based
on the death of the Superman comic book
arc explored Superman's feelings of
being an outsider but Byrne wanted to
completely reinvent the world Superman
existed in pulling it from the bright
and hopeful depiction of dick Donna's
movies and plunging him into something
closer to Ridley Scott's alien but for
every good idea there was an incredibly
bad one
good idea Brainiac as the villain
destroys Krypton and aims to finish the
job by killing Superman bad idea
Brainiac would also merge with Lex
Luthor to become a new two-headed super
villain called alexia guys Lex Luthor
Brainiac
put it in my movie Superman lives was
fraught with issues ranging from
multiple script rewrites to over zealous
producers pulling the project in strange
directions one for example said Superman
shouldn't be able to fly or wear his
iconic suit and that there should be a
battle with a giant spider eventually
when the project had eaten up millions
of dollars it was canceled which is a
shame because it could have been really
something amazing with a little
refinement oh and that producer with the
giant spider idea remember Kenneth
Branagh in wild wild west same guy
back in 2012 The Hollywood Reporter
reported that Warner Brothers were
interested in making a live-action
adaptation of Pinocchio using a real boy
everything boom was attached to direct
and his first choice of the iconic role
of Geppetto was Robert Downey jr. now
you might not immediately think of
Robert Downey jr. for the role but
honestly he can get away with anything
oh dude disguises another do by the time
in Tropic Thunder where he a white
American actor ends up playing an
Australian actor who in turn plays a
black American soldier who then played a
Vietnamese rice farmer is this right
yeah oh dear sadly Byrne passed on the
project to direct miss Peregrine's Home
for peculiar children but the film has
finally resurfaced with Da Vinci Code
director Ron Howard overseeing Downey
jr. is Geppetto hopefully you can do for
woodcarvers what Patrick Swayze did
first sexy ghost Potter's goosebumps
looks were pretty big back in the 90s
kids would spend their time poring over
RL Stein's latest book or sat in front
of the goggle box getting secondhand
anxiety from all those papers escaping
from that briefcase maybe that just says
a lot about me as a child
in 1998 Burton was attached to produce
the live-action adaptation and
everything was pretty much good to go
apart from one tiny little crucial
detail first ripped RL Stine remarked
that they couldn't get a script we liked
or decide what book or monster to do so
it just languished there were 17 or 18
scripts and I sort of lost track of it
entirely because I was busy writing the
books the project eventually came to
fruition in
fifteen starring Jack Black some would
say almost 15 years late some would say
that me I'd say that so there we are six
of the coolest and kookiest Tim Burton
projects that never really made it off
the ground which would you have loved to
have seen made don't worry in some
sliding doors parallel universe that
Nicolas Cage Superman movie exists for
more videos like this one make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to GameSpot universe
and we'll see you next time okay ladies
now let's get information whoa
the Bernanos go is going crazy guys guys
it's difficult to flip up you have to
probably get underneath them framing
tomorrow me and the Burton